CHANNING TATUM: God,
all these stones, man.
Look at them.
They're just massive boulders.
BEAR GRYLLS: Nope,
it's a dead end.
So all of this area is
endless, like, dead ends.
You reach a cliff face or you
reach a boulder you can't get
over, you try and go round it.
Wow, this is
looking pretty cool.
[suspenseful music]
I actually think there's a
hint of light through this one.
We've now reached
what looks like a kind
of narrow, dark hole of a cave.
But I've seen a glimmer
of light through it.
And I'm thinking,
actually, we don't
need that much to get through.
Even if it's that wide,
we reach the end of it,
we'll get through it.
Let's make a little torch.
CHANNING TATUM: Yeah.
We'll do it from
that birch bark.
And then go in there,
use that for light,
and see if we can
climb up through.
And that'll then access to the
top part of this boulder face.
CHANNING TATUM: All right.
So what we need--
that birch stuff's good.
Let me go and cut a stick.
Into the belly of the beast.
I was like, oh, we
won't go in there.
Um, we're going in there.
And there's, like,
a little speck of--
[laughs]
--of light.
Have you ever seen "Descent"?
[woman screaming]
I really hope that's
not happening today.
Copy that, if you never see me
again, you know where I'm at--
(WHISPERING) Norway
with Bear Grylls.
Help.
BEAR GRYLLS: And then
we need the chaga.
OK.
There we go.
That's better.
Where's that little
flint you had?
Well, some of it's here.
So this is old school.
That's flint.
And then this is, like,
what they call a knap.
And they used to just
carry this around.
You just go-- you can see it.
But it's hard.
You got to--
So technically, I was wrong.
The Norwegian chip thing was
not a mustache protector.
I'm OK with admitting that.
BEAR GRYLLS: So hold the
metal bit down, yeah.
And then just flick
the flint along it.
[clinking]
There you go.
We've got it.
There.
CHANNING TATUM: Sick.
And there you go.
Wow.
CHANNING TATUM: I've never
started a fire as easy as this.
I mean, it's a one tiny,
little spark, barely an ember.
And it just, like, ignited and
burning slowly into this stuff
called chaga.
OK.
Hold that.
You ready?
CHANNING TATUM: Yes, sir.
BEAR GRYLLS: Let's do it.